foreign
my name is Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spider-Man and things are
going great oh yeah you were supposed to
be here goodbye all right whatever
whatever wow whatever
so are you like a cow or a Dalmatian I
am
spot
that's not funny
don't don't do that
miles's grades are pretty good A and AP
Physics that's my little man and a B in
Spanish what what okay miles
to you and I think you know it
[Music]
wanna get out of here oh when
so wait a minute there's an elite crew
with all the best spider people in it
who's the new guy this is unbelievable
this is the lobby
Miguel O'Hara the whole thing was his
idea what's it I gotta do to join this
spider team you can never be part of
this don't even get me started on Doctor
Strange and a little nerd back on Earth
1999.99
he had a terrible fatigue
Z you have a baby
I'll take it from here
miles being Spider-Man is a sacrifice
you have a choice between saving one
person
and saving every world
send me home I can't do that I can do
both
your man always always what about Uncle
Ben if not for Uncle Ben most of us
wouldn't be here
you can't run forever dude
[Music]
there's no idea what are you doing
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go nah
I'm gonna do my own thing
stop Spiderman
[Music]
thank you
let me guess he died